We had so much fun with pendulums and simple harmonic motion in Unit 5
that we decided to bring them back for Unit 6.
For this problem we're going to imagine we have a pendulum here.
And this time it's not gravity pulling on the pendulum. It's an electric field.
The ball here at the end of the pendulum has some positive charge q,
which causes it to interact with the electric field in a way very similar
to the gravitational field we saw before.
And just to make our lives easier, we're going to assume that this electric field is constant
just like we were looking at in those parallel plate problems.
All right--so my question to you is, how was replacing the gravitational field
with this electric field going to affect the behavior of our pendulum?
Well it turns out that even with an electric field instead of a gravitational field,
the pendulum will still have simple harmonic motion
and if this pendulum is in simple harmonic motion that means it has some period t.
Given that the length of the pendulum is 0.75 m, that the mass of the ball on the end is 0.02 kg,
the electric field has a constant strength of 10 N/C, and the charge of the ball on the end is 0.01 C,
can you tell me what the period of this simple harmonic oscillation is going to be?
Put your answer here in seconds.
Keep in mind when you're doing this problem that just like with a normal pendulum
this approximation that it's simple harmonic motion is actually only true for small angle θ.
And that's the same case here.
When you're working on this problem you can safely assume that
we're only dealing with small values of θ--all right, good luck.